[Musique]
les vrais roses utilisaient en
parfumerie ou de floral pétale rouge vif
ou d'un blanc délicat depuis le 30 mai
le public est invité à s'émerveiller
dans le jardin du parfumeur situé au
coeur du domaine de Trianon à Versailles
dans cet espace de 9000 m² situé autour
de l'Orangerie de Châteauneuf près de
300 espèces peuvent être admirées par
les visiteurs pour une expérience
sensorielle soit
esthétique et
c'est quelque chose de nouveau surtout
parce que dans ces contextes ils peuvent
vraiment se balader en liberté dans
entre les massifs et c'est une chose que
c'est pas possible dans les autres
parties de domaine jasmin camomille ou
sureau le choix des végétaux s'est fait
en collaboration avec Francis kurdjian
formé dans une grande école de
parfumerie à Versailles des variétés
sélectionnées pour leur fragrance et
planté dans l'esprit des jardins de
Trianon du 17e siècle
qui sont très parfumés quand on a fait
la conception on a cherché des des
insérer
des fleurs qui sont des hybrides récents
mais qu'ils ont à l'intérieur des points
de vue olfactive c'est une vitrine parce
que on n'a pas assez d'espace pour
produire la quantité telle est
nécessaire pour avoir une production
intéressante pour prolonger l'expérience
le château de Versailles organisé
également des ateliers pour découvrir le
secret de fabrication des parfums
présentation des ingrédients et des
méthodes d'extraction des connaissances
à acquérir dans ce jardin de curiosité
jusqu'à la fin de l'été